you need to wipe down
what's with the jeans I was just doing
my daily perusing porn when I came
across this gem the entire video is full
of bud burps oh my god it's opening a
shot that you just sent me is pretty
fucking gnarly man what is it is it just
for you so that we can't show what is it
it's a woman getting another woman's ass
in a really compromising position
anything you want to see it oh okay I
get it
okay I got it I got it why does that to
gape like that oh my god it is dirty
does that so why do they have to open it
up all the time like wine I have to make
the butthole open why is your mouth so
big big cuz she shits a lot I don't know
I don't know I think what they say
things like um you know I like it dirty
and dirty in insects terms it is usually
like that's awesome but when you said
like a dirty asshole it just it's a kind
of different arm yeah it's a different
meaning
really like shitty asshole